so at the first sign of a stroke what
should someone
do let's say you're with a friend or a
family member
and you notice a potential sign of a
stroke
what should you do first let's talk
about what are the signs
of a stroke you have numbness in one
side of your body it could be
the face it could be even an arm or a
leg confusion
loss of facial function loss of arm
function
on one side loss of leg function slurred
speech
trouble walking there's a real easy way
to
remember some key factors and it's
stands for fast
so the face okay so if you have the
person next to you that
you suspect they just had a stroke have
them smile
okay and if one side of their face
droops
that could be an indicator because you
lose
facial function on one side the next
factor is the arm
have them raise both of their arms and
if
one side just drops down that could be
an indication
of a stroke the next point is have them
speak
you ask them to repeat a phrase a few
times
and see if they can do it if they start
slurring
that can be a sign of a stroke now
realize there's a very short window
to get this person to the hospital so
they can actually give them
some type of anti-clotting medication to
open up the clot into the brain so the
brain can get
oxygen it's like a three to four hour
window
so you want to probably call
now just as 911 as knowing what to do if
someone actually is having a stroke
it's what to do to prevent a stroke the
most important thing
is getting your diet corrected so your
insulin
is normalized so you don't have high
insulin because then you develop insulin
resistance
and when you have that you have a lot of
blood sugar issues and you can form a
clot
just with that condition right up the
bat so you want to do
a low carb healthy diet also you want to
do a diet rich in potassium a lot of
leafy greens would be very important
potassium helps support the vascular
system and it can also inhibit
clotting vitamin e specifically the
tocopherols
are probably one of the best
antioxidants to support the brain
and free radical damage because what's
unique about the brain
is that there's a tremendous amount of
oxygen
consumption so you have a lot of free
radicals and oxidants going on
so you need a good antioxidant vitamin e
the tocopherol version is the best
number four ketones so if you're on a
ketogenic diet
if you're doing mct oil if you take
exogenous ketones
all support the brain the brain
loves ketones better than glucose
and ketones are kind of the opposite
fuel to glucose
glucose tends to create more clots
ketones
can inhibit clots also fasting
intermittent fasting is very very
beneficial
to the brain and also causing your body
to
recycle old damaged protein and so one
of the most important things
to support both your cardiovascular
system
the inside of the lining of your
arteries and the brain
is intermittent fasting all sorts of
magical things
happen then we have dha which is omega-3
fatty acids
omega-3 fatty acids not only thin the
blood
as does vitamin e but it also can help
repair
brain damage and protect the brain
against
clotting garlic is a good blood thinner
then we have exercise which is going to
support more oxygen
to the brain cells one last therapy
which i have done and i love is
is the hyperbaric oxygen therapy you
should look into it if you haven't heard
about it
and it can create some serious
improvement if you actually had a stroke
and you're trying to force oxygen deep
into the brain
to repair it hey before you go real
quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about
here
what about strengthening your immune
system
that's what's missing this course will
show you how to bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today